this morning Commission has updated the
Council on the state of play with
respect to the yellow card procedure for
the revised posting of workers directive
the presidency also presented a progress
report on the negotiations on the
carcinogens directive good progress has
been made and hopefully the next
presidency will be able to come to an
agreement and also we hopefully adopt
two sets of Council conclusions on
gender equality and on LGBTI this is
very important in the set days after the
Orlando attacks that homophobia is
addressed also at EU level this year
country-specific commendations enjoyed
member states to focus on increasing
employment strengthening human capital
and improving social inclusion and
protection the council conclusions are
in line with the Commission's approach
on social dialogue notably the
priorities on more actively involving
the social partners in economic
governance and on the role of social
partners in EU policy and law making let
me develop very shortly on two aspects
in the skills agenda that is the skills
guarantee and that is the proposal to
revise the European qualifications
framework we launched this idea of a
skills guarantee this means that we will
ask member states to for a commitment to
put a three-way approach in place for
low-skilled people first an assessment
to see what are their needs what is the
level of knowledge what do they know
what do they can secondly a tailor-made
package or an tailor-made offer to
upskill those people and thirdly that
it's possible for those people that they
can document the newly obtained skills a
second element of our skills package is
the qualifications framework we will
improve that and also make it possible
that we can use that framework to screen
the skills of people from third
countries on pharmaceutical policy we
would like to give a strong political
message that change is necessary
in the way the current from a suitable
system is working on antimicrobial
resistance we agreed that each member
state should develop by mid-2017 a
national action plan based on the one
health approach and in line with the
waho global action plan we adopted a
roadmap to action on food products
improvement we aim to improve the offer
of foods by reducing the amounts of salt
saturated fats added sugars and energy
fighting I Amar's long been a priority
for the Commission following a one
health approach in this area I am very
pleased that the conclusion stressed the
commitment to improve coordination in
particular saluda one Health Network I
welcome the conclusions on strengthening
the balance in the pharmaceutical
systems in the EU and its member states
another pressing issue on the agenda was
food reformulation a council conclusions
a doublet today are a further step to
increase awareness and push afford
action to improve nutrition at both
european union national levels